there's new evidence of the national
push to break out of the bubbles we've
all been living in during this pandemic
free give us free all across the country
americans are taking planes and trains
and automobiles too
this memorial day weekend families are
coming together again
thanks to the covid vaccines one in four
americans say they plan to travel this
weekend that's according to a new poll
of course that also is going to mean
very heavy traffic on the road
errol barnett is on the new jersey
turnpike for some first-hand reporting
there he is sitting in the passenger
seat that's good that's right
errol how's it going hey there gail good
morning well look the good news
is we're moving but the bad news is it
is early
we're moving southbound down the new
jersey turnpike right now this is a
major artery of course
for the northeast region and the folks
you see around me are among the 34
million americans expected to drive
right now and through the weekend it's
really the bulk of holiday
travelers these are numbers we haven't
seen since before the pandemic but
what's interesting is that as i speak to
people and what we hear
again and again and again is that after
14 months under lockdown
folks are just desperate to reconnect
this is our first time seeing each other
in a very long
time kerry fitzpatrick returned from
deployment in the middle east
just in time for memorial day weekend
her fiance trisha hutchins
being away from your partner for almost
a year is is a lot especially during
a year with a pandemic fitzpatrick is
one of more than 37 million people
expected to travel this weekend
a 60 percent increase from last year
when most of us were in the pandemic
lockdown
i'm really excited we've been cooped up
in our houses for so long that it's
really fun to have an opportunity to
finally get out to be able to fly again
is wonderful to be able to go
with really hardly any restrictions and
be able to take my mom out
is a blessing super excited it's her
birthday so we're going to celebrate for
a week
for her most americans are choosing to
drive but airports are seeing more
flyers than they have in
over a year this is what lax looked like
12 months ago
compared to this week parks and beaches
which were empty this time last year
are also bracing for holiday crowds we
had an opportunity we got vaccinated we
came down
while those like kimber veltry say being
vaccinated makes for safer travel
there are other concerns i am a little
apprehensive about the planes being
fuller and it seems like
tensions are really high on planes
overnight southwest airlines confirmed
it banned this passenger for punching a
flight attendant last weekend
during a dispute meanwhile veltry who is
visiting her sister in nashville this
weekend
is just looking forward to being
reunited with loved ones
i'll probably cry a lot we're a crying
family so
we'll just probably cry like every six
hours because we're so excited to be
together
i suspect many tears tears of joy will
be spread this weekend
now despite the surge and travel that
we're seeing it's still six
million fewer americans or 13 percent
less than we saw
in 2019 so these are not numbers that
match
pre-pandemic levels but anthony no
matter where you're heading this weekend
by rail or road or by air you know be
patient take your time and of course
stay safe
people are coming back that's great
errol thank you